the sudden spread of monkey pox has
puzzled scientists so what do we know
well this is the virus first identifying
laboratory monkeys in 1958 then in
humans in 1970 there are two strains
endemic to parts of africa the central
african subtype can cause severe
symptoms including large lesions on the
skin with a fatality rate of around 10
percent the west african version causing
the current outbreak results in milder
symptoms including a rash that blisters
and scabs over a bit like chicken pox it
can be worse than children infected
people can also have flu-like symptoms
of fever muscle aches and pains chills
and exhaustion
in africa the virus is primarily spread
by wild animals including rodents it
doesn't transmit easily between people
but the virus can spread by direct skin
to skin contact towels bedding and the
clothing of people with active infection
as well as droplets from coughs and
sneezes but isn't thought to be airborne
like kovid
before the current outbreak the seven uk
cases since 2018 were all in travelers
returning from west africa or people in
their household now that's what makes
this outbreak so unusual with
communities spread in multiple countries
well away from endemic regions
so what could be driving the sudden
surge well first the virus could have
changed to become more transmissible
most scientists think this is unlikely
it is a dna virus with two strands of
genetic material that are in effect an
autocorrect feature that stops the rapid
mutation rate seen in single stranded
rna viruses like kovid
the second possibility is that it is now
by chance in people who have more social
contacts according to the uk health
security agency most but not all cases
are gay bisexual or men who have sex
with men it says the virus may be
spreading through sexual networks not a
sexually transmitted disease in the
normal sense but through close and
sometimes intimate physical contact
people with the virus and their direct
or household contacts are being asked to
self-isolate for three weeks
infected people generally recover
without any treatment and the context
may be offered a smallpox vaccine which
is also effective at stopping symptoms
of monkey pox
the risk of picking up the virus is low
we're not in a covet situation but this
is another animal virus spreading
between people for reasons scientists
can't yet explain and they're keen to
shut it down